as we go to our next game,
Moon Landing.
Yeah, wipe off your coke noses.
Now, nearly 50 years ago,
millions of people
around the world
watched what is arguably
the number-two most important
achievement in history--
the second man on the moon.
12 minutes after Neil Armstrong
stepped in full on the lunar
surface with his famous words,
"That's one step for man, that's
one giant leap for mankind",
his co-pilot Buzz Aldrin slammed
onto the dust and shouted,
"Buzz Aldrin has arrived,
motherfuckers!"
I'm paraphrasing, but, uh, today
is Buzz Aldrin's 86th birthday.
So comedians, please
give me some other badass
or just plain bad
moon landing quotes
in 60 seconds, and begin.
Jordan.
Whassup?
All right, points.
Bryan.
One small step for man,
'cause women be shopping.
Poin... Points.
Erin.
Started from the bottom,
now I'm here.
All right, points.
Jordan.
Hey, Neil, take a picture
where it looks like
I'm fucking Denmark.
Points.
Erin.
Oh, my God, this is incredible--
my dick is floating.
Points.
Bryan.
Do I look fat?
Points.
Jordan.
Oh, shit, my edibles
are kicking in-- I lo...
Points. Bryan.
Really-- not a single Starbucks?
All right, points.
Bryan.
Guys, the moon sucks.
Yeah, points.
There is nothing up here.